[Musique]
aujourd'hui on nous annonce un séminaire
on nous dit qu emmanuel macron est
préoccupé sur la question de
l'immigration dans notre pays
mais ce que je voudrais ce qu'ils soient
en adéquation avec ses actes parce que
on le voit bien depuis laissé les
chiffres vous savez qu'il parle monsieur
équilibre depuis qu emmanuel macron est
au pouvoir on n'a jamais eu autant de
titres de séjour qui ont été délivrés
plus de 255 milles donc on parler c'est
bien c'est preuve d'une forme de
réalisme mais je doute que ce soit suivi
d'effets compte tenu d'ailleurs des
propos qui ont été tenus par sam dans sa
majorité
moi je vais des mesures concrètes et qui
là et qu'il accepte aussi les
propositions que nous faisons pour
l'instant toutes ont été rejetées
donc à mon envie de ce qui fait que de
la com ce singe je pense que grippe il
ya un an voter un texte tout cas au
sénat nous l'avons pas voter nous
l'avons critique et qui était portée par
gérard collomb asile immigration
ça fait exactement un an que cette loi a
été promulguée et alors voilà le
président de la république qui se dit
parce que sans doute que pour les
sondages pour son électorat
il ya peut-être d'autres clins d'oeil à
la droite ou à la droite de la droite à
faire et il fait cette sortie là la
médecine reparler corps et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui de la procréation
médicalement assistée telle qu'elle
existait aujourd'hui la pma elle est
ouverte à des couples qui sont affectés
dont l'un des deux partenaires est
infecté par une infertiles il va être
question d'offrir la même technique le
même geste technique à des personnes qui
pour le coup ne sont pas malades une
femme seule ne peut pas avoir d'enfant
non pas parce que les affectés par une
stérilité pathologique mais simplement
parce que la manière dont elles vivent à
y ait un corps seul un corps tout seul
le mien non plus ne peut pas avoir
d'enfant tout seul ce qui concerne la
pma la grande question c'est de savoir
jusqu'où va-t-on pour satisfaire des
désirs ou pour ses pour soulager des
souffrances aussi
moi je pense qu'on ne peut pas aller
jusqu'à certaines limites
[Musique]